so i i i think it'd be a cool trick if
you could
turn the sun
into a transparent ball of gas rather
than the plasma that it is yeah and just
watch that happen and then it would just
basically disappear right and you get to
see what was behind it can you pour some
cold water in there no that that's all
you need
just add a little bit of cold
[Music]
this is star talk
cosmic queries edition neil degrasse
tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
and today i've got matt kirschen with me
as my co-host matt how you doing man
i'm good thanks i'm coming to you from
sunny colorado i'm at the in-laws house
right now so at the in-laws do we really
need to know like you know is it
i'm just i'm just letting you know this
just so that if anyone's watching the
video rather than just pure audio you
know that this arrangement behind me was
not my doing this is uh
it's already been commented by lindsay
the producer that i look the most like
the professor out of anyone on this zoom
right now you've been working in clean
offices i've got
papers reference books i feel very
educated right now
let's see okay now i gotta hold up that
side of what of that promise uh yeah so
matt matt's a your comedian and you host
a podcast uh mostly science that i did
probably probably science
probably science one day i'll get i'll
it'll be completely so close so close
and i've been a guest on your program
and i've enjoyed it and i'm waiting for
my invitation to come back oh well
you've got a book coming out soon
haven't you you've gotta you've yeah
like not now but yeah in a while okay if
that's if that's enough to get me back
on your show i'm delighted well i i
never i never want to ruin my uh i don't
want to overplay my hand when it comes
to getting the big guns on the show
so we're here because we've got a topic
that
uh is is at the beginning of everything
right we're the subject today is the big
bang the cosmic microwave background
inflation the origin of the universe
everything that started at the beginning
and i have some
expertise there but not enough to like
drive an entire cosmic query so we went
combing
the universe
and we found professor brian keating
brian welcome to star talk thank you you
found the only one who uh was willing at
this particular time to come on
[Laughter]
no you were high on our list
we've had operatives following you for a
while so you're a cosmologist uh
chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics university of california san
diego ucsd and you got a podcast of your
own which i was also a guest on
i love the title of that one into the
impossible so that just sounds like fun
where you take the guests and where you
take the audience
and so we've got you here just uh let's
lay some some fundamentals just for the
show before we go to matt as he digs up
the questions we've solicited from our
patreon members but just just
uh what is like the three biggest
reasons why
we're all convinced that the big bang
was a real thing
well i think there there's multiple
pieces of evidence but i think none
stronger is the fact that we exist and
we're made of matter
and that matter came from somewhere and
where it came from i think is uh is best
described in the least ignorant form of
uh description as the big bang it means
a lot to of different things some
correct things some incorrect things but
the fact that there's sort of shrapnel
left over from the most cataclysmic
explosion literally in the history of
the cosmos uh the the biggest uh
explosion that ever could be envisioned
uh it it is perhaps not surprising that
cosmologists such as myself
look to whatever's left over from this
explosion to tell us what it was like
when that explosion happened and i think
the problem that that the layperson has
is the conflation not the inflation
we'll get to that but the conflation of
the big bang with the origin of time
with the origin of the universe and they
need not be synonymous and i think
that's the most interesting development
in the last few years is this
realization that
what we call the big bang is really the
terminus on a voyage backwards from
today uh where our ignorance
really ends which is which is at this at
this epoch when the first elements in
the periodic table were formed and that
took place in a period of time uh much
much shorter than an episode of the big
bang theory uh tv show
so i think it's fascinating that we are
all leftover byproducts you know your
friend uh and mentor carl sagan we
talked about when you were on the into
the impossible podcast he used to say
we're all star stuff but most of us is
hydrogen uh and uh that hydrogen came
from the big bang so we're actually big
bang stuff more than we are uh star
stones i like that better i want to be
big bang stuff
i mean that does sound a bit like a scar
band oh yeah yeah very very very good i
was just gonna say that there was a
there's a sentence you said a phrase you
said in the middle of that that really
struck me where you said the big bang is
where our ignorant ends because i think
you know i would have
certainly younger me and probably me
just now would have said it's where our
knowledge ends
he's coming the other way on the time
vector there okay once you have the big
bang everything was before that we're
like ignorant of and we're poking in the
dark and now
our knowledge begins going forward did i
get you right there yeah that's
absolutely right okay yeah so so matt
you were thinking backwards on that one
in spite of all the books that are in
your space there i know if only any of
them were physics
or i had read any of them
well there's a lovely japanese word
which uh which i i love to bring out on
my friends and except if they're
japanese many of my collaborators are
it's called i think it's called sanduku
not sudoku but sanduko it's the art of
buying books without the intention of
reading them and
yeah they have a word for everything
they got a word for that
you know they're like that's a word for
everything neil oh my gosh we need that
word
[Laughter]
so tell me also about inflation what
everyone's heard so much about i mean i
i all i remember is it sort of came
online in the late 70s when there was
actual hyperinfl not hyper but very high
inflation in the united states highest
ever at the time actually that's right
it was in the teens per year
and so
uh so the word was sort of contemporary
with
modern economics but it was it's a legit
word yeah applying in the early universe
what was the need for it because it
feels like an add-on to the big bang i
mean who ordered that right exactly the
big man was was kind of doing okay
without it no we need inflation
and now we're fine okay that's right
yeah i always say you know our job as
cosmologists when one of my students
graduates i tell i tell him or her i say
congratulations you've now earned your
ticket to an even harder problem you
know because our job is to find the
flaws in the currently existing
paradigms of of the universe so what
happened originally we go back way back
we go back to to this guy uh you know
i'm sorry to infringe upon matt's
territory i don't know matt if you're a
prop comic but i'm a prop cosmic i like
all my cosmology puppets i got one of
neil in my office i broke that out last
time but here's galileo we'll break them
out as necessary but brian is holding up
finger puppets uh sock puppets of
various people okay albert and he just
held up albert einstein yeah so einstein
and many of his uh contemporaries for
thousands of years prior to him believe
the universe was eternal static perhaps
cyclic if you go back way far be before
uh in the egyptian cosmology of the you
know thousands of bce years
people believed in either cyclic or
static some version of an eternally
existing universe and it wasn't until
the late 1920s when the notion uh that
the universe was dynamic and not static
came into into play based on evidence
collected by uh vesto schleifer
henrietta levitt and of course edwin
hobble and uh and these scientists
ushered in this notion that was allied
with a theoretical uh uh you know
conception by a belgian priest named
lemaitre
that the universe could have been and
should have been much smaller in the
past if today it's much much larger and
tomorrow will be larger yet so the
notion that the universe began with the
big bang really got ushered in that
epoch but um and it's less than 100
years old it's pretty fascinating to
think about that and it's had its own
incarnations but it was dissolved to
solve a problem in the pre-existing
cosmogeny uh the origin of the universe
not existing that it being static
eternal well that was inconsistent with
evidence big bang comes along boom that
supplants it with evidence and data i
see what you did there you said boom
yeah
i put a bang in there every so often
per my contract
with big bang productions uh and then as
often happens uh the ticket you know
that i said is uh to solving a problem
is a new problem and so people realize
the i'm going to drop another word on
you that neil will know but our british
friend might not uh lacuna you know we
have a gap in our in our in our
understanding based on the data based on
the observations that there was
something in commensurate with the big
bang theory that couldn't be explained
namely how the universe got its spots
behind me i have a beach ball if you're
watching and if you're listening it's an
inflatable beach ball produced by the
wmap team neil's friend david spurgle
and others have produced a beach ball
representation of the fluctuations in
the cosmic mercury background which is
what i study i assume we'll get into
that and other features of the universe
became incompatible with a universe that
was
that was purely emerging from a
singularity or from a very compact dense
state and to explain the peculiarities
that were observed in the data in the
1970s as neil said we required some kind
of explanation that explanation was
conceived by alan guth and and paul
steinhardt and um
andre linde and many other stephen
hawking
to have different features of at what we
now call inflation but the difference is
that there's sort of there is evidence
for inflation but i would say it's more
circumstantial so what inflation
explains is why the universe is so large
so so flat and possessing tiny
fluctuations and also having other
properties that we can observe in the
data
about the various amounts of particles
energy forces and fields right now
inflation is about seven percent so what
percent inflation
sorry
can i take it further back
because i i'm confused here and just
so just to be clear there's a difference
between inflation and expansion because
expansion has been
expansion is what we i've i've known you
know learning from like school physics
is the universe is expanding we know
that from like red shift from doppler
effect and you reverse it back and
that's how you calculate when the big
bang happened correct what's inflation
and how is that different you could
think of inflation if you think of the
big bang as an explosion it's not an
explosion in the conventional sense but
uh it could be helpful to think about it
as an explosion happening everywhere at
a single moment in time if if indeed
that that did launch the uh the origin
of time we can talk about that but the
the spark that ignited that explosion if
you will uh relies in the inflation
paradigm on a quantum field a new object
a new entity in the inventory of the
energy budget of the universe and that
energy is provided by a quantum field
called the inflaton or inflaton
and that drove this exponential
expansion of the universe that happened
a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second
after the big bang if the big bang was
indeed the origin and a singularity in
the classical conception of that term
and that lasted for less than a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
and in that time the universe inflated
from a grapefruit size to 30 orders of
magnitude larger than a grapefruit size
and that happened at a rate if you
calculate how fast that would occur it's
far ex in excess of the speed of light
and so it's the ultimate energy
injection into the universe it has many
properties
uh in common with what we call dark
energy and the cosmic acceleration that
we observed today that was awarded to a
nobel prize was awarded to three
physicists in 2011
dark energy cosmic acceleration that new
field which we just call dark energy has
many properties in common with the
inflation occurrence but the inflation
would have occurred 13 billion years
almost 14 billion years earlier so
inflation is the spark that gives the
impetus that causes the universe to
expand to the vast size that it is today
in an exponentially small amount of time
and that explains why the universe has
the particular pattern of microwave
background fluctuations that my
colleagues and i studied so so i want to
go to our quick questions real quick but
yeah just just frankly brian if i would
hearing all that for the first time um
it sounds like you just made it all up
just now it sounds like
oh i can't explain that how about
inflation yeah okay how about
yeah that's a ticket yeah
let's go let's go to you know those
books neil that that say everything i
needed to learn i learned about in
kindergarten well and everything you
need to learn about inflation you can
learn in advanced quantum mechanics okay
all right well there you go so matt give
me what you have for us so there's a
there's a bunch of questions immediately
right on this subject so chris love asks
regarding the cosmic microwave
background whenever i see an image that
represents it there are hot and cold
spots all over it i'm curious what the
mechanism might be that causes those hot
and cold spots is it the distribution of
normal matter dark matter the expansion
of space time or something else thank
you for the knowledge
and also you know because all those maps
are color coded to represent temperature
we're left with the impression that you
touch one spot it feels hot you touch
one spot it feels cold so but that's not
no this this that's just to help the the
viewer yeah in a sense yeah they really
are hotter or colder but let me explain
first so yeah but by how much oh well a
very very you know frosty uh ten one
millionths of a degree kelvin yes
exactly you're not you're not going to
pick that up on your on your edmond side
right so the hot sections
are about 100 micro kelvin hotter than
the average cmb temperature which is 2.7
kelvin got it got it so 2.7 kelvin which
is
which is
400 yeah it's a frosty day in denver
where you're at matt it would be 454
degrees below zero fahrenheit i just
want to make it clear that we say
they're hot and cold spots but the the
the range in that temperature is
smaller than any two places in the room
you're in
that's right
well neil well neil you know better than
anybody you know what cosmologists will
call a crisis the fact that a boson has
a one billionth of a percent more mass
than a than it was expected to that's a
crisis yeah yeah but let me see i'm not
jumping on any windows on that one
that's right
yeah so so to uh to explain these
fluctuations in the cosmic microwave
background let's explain what the cmb is
the cmb is the cosmic microwave
background it's an all-pervasive field
of photons coming to us as if we're
inside of an enormous oven and that oven
thank god for us is only at a
temperature of 2.7 degrees above
absolute zero or 450 or so degrees below
zero fahrenheit and that was discovered
in 1965 in of all places new jersey and
i'm a new yorker neil so i can make fun
of new jersey i have a ticket i have a
license to do that so it was discovered
in holmdale new jersey by penzias and
wilson they couldn't get rid of it no
matter where they looked when they
looked how they looked this background
radiation comes to us in all directions
and they thought it was perfectly
uniform but over the decades
cosmologists realized it has major
amounts of a very difficult word to
pronounce for the first time but
anisotropy
so anisotropy means not isotropic
isotropic means it looks the same
everywhere you look
and and so these are notions that have
to be explained why is the universe very
very close to perfectly uniform but it's
not perfectly uniform we've known since
the time of isaac newton the finger
puppet somewhere around here uh isaac
newton said if the universe were
perfectly static and isotropic
everywhere you looked then we would
never form there'd be nothing to break
the symmetry and say oh a planet should
form here a star should form there uh
under matter would just be equally
spread everywhere yeah it would never it
would never condense and collapse and
form uh form-bound gravitational
structures so so we've known that the
universe couldn't be perfectly uniform
in that everywhere you looked in the
universe you saw the exact same
temperature right but the question asked
what's causing it yeah so what's causing
it was the reason that inflation needed
to be explained so in the inflationary
paradigm the explanation comes from the
fact that the thing that blew up the
universe by 30 orders of magnitude from
an initial cosmic primeval seed
was a fluctuation in a quantum field
what's called a scalar field and that
field i called it before the inflaton
this quantum field
like all quantum fields like the higgs
boson like the photon field like any
field that you so choose in
in physics has
unavoidable irreducible quantum
fluctuations a quantum fluctuation is an
expression of the heisenberg uncertainty
principle that you can't know exactly
all the information about a quantum
field or quantum particle a photon an
electron a crouton my favorite particle
you can't know everything about them
with infinite precision if you do you
have complete uncertainty in other
aspects of its of its property so one
thing we know is that at this extremely
brief epoch of time
in inflation there would have been large
fluctuations in the amount of energy in
the universe and einstein says that all
forms of energy are equivalent to sort
of a mass fluctuation via the most
famous equation in all of science equals
mc squared
so the theory is this the in photon is a
quantum field it like all quantum fields
has fluctuations those fluctuations can
be equated to sort of mass in
homogeneities and those mass in
homogeneities then according to
einstein's general theory of relativity
equate to the curvature of space time
which the questioner asked about so if
you look at the fundamental logic of
progression inflation explains the c and
b fluctuations by the fact that this
quantum field had these irreducible
perturbations these fluctuations thanks
to heisenberg
now all this presupposes that inflation
exists which we don't know about and
what my team of scientists in the
simon's observatory is attempting to do
is build an experiment an instrument to
collect data to provide evidence for
those quantum fluctuations and we can
get into how we do that but the base
answer to that question that was very
astutely posed by the audience
is
is that they do represent actual over
densities in temperature and in matter
in the early universe that were caused
by primordial seeds themselves caused by
fluctuations in this quantum field so i
know it sounds complicated but i mean
your audience is pretty brilliant so as
lady gaga says born that way
that's what's okay
all right we're going there we're going
there take a quick break when we come
back we'll get right back into questions
with our guest brian keating who is a
cosmologist who's taking us back to the
beginning of things the beginning of
time space energy and all that and i got
matt kirschen helping me out here when
we return
we're back star talk cosmic queries
cosmology big bang edition
with cosmologist brian keating who hosts
a podcast into the impossible
which uh brian that comes from a quote
from arthur c clarke is that right yeah
that's right yeah so when you you're on
my podcast i'll i'll have you back on
hopefully this fall and it's a famous
quote uh arthur c clarke so i direct
co-direct the arthur c clark center for
human imagination at uc san diego excuse
me yes that's right
in my spare time
and uh sir arthur had many aphorisms
many cosmic quips one of them that you
like is
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert he also said for every
uh any advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and they
said
the only way to determine the limits of
the possible is to go beyond them into
the impossible so that's the origin of
our podcast cool into the impossible one
other thing before we pick up our next
question with matt
we're in
this year we're in the 2020s
and this is like the centennial
decade
of all kinds of
wild freaky discoveries made in the
1920s
brian and and i i when i think back on
that to me the 1920s must have been the
the greatest watershed decade in physics
of any decade there ever has been
or perhaps will be
from the expanding universe to the
einstein you know and they were trying
to figure out einstein there's any
special memory you have yeah
yeah well i'm not quite that old neil
but uh oh okay but it's true yeah you've
held up well no no
the discovery of uh of anti-matter the
prediction of anti-matter quantum field
theory all these wonderful things yeah
you're right and alexander friedman uh
we're chatting about off air you know he
came up a hundred years ago in 1922.
with uh the initial framework for what
would later become known as the friedman
equations which are the derivation from
einstein's theory of general relativity
that the universe can either expand or
contract but it can't really be static
unless you put in as einstein did a
fudge factor which he called the
cosmological term or the vacuum term the
lambda term and he was steadfastly in
opposition to uh to these predictions
refined by uh george lumatra later on in
fact einstein said famously uh your uh
your mathematics is exquisite uh
lemaitre and friedman but your physics
is atrocious and you know it's just one
of the many blunders that einstein had
you know it's too bad neil because he
could have had a good career
i know i know i know but but since at
the end of the day
uh this cosmological constant was real
yeah all right
and the dark energy term uh what what i
like saying is that einstein's biggest
blunder was saying that that was his
biggest blunder
never enjoyed it never
he's so badass that even when he was
wrong he was right that's right and
we're still fighting things out about
him that he uh he predicted and now are
only now being verified exactly exactly
so matt give me some more dude this is
great by the way
there's a bunch of people's questions
that have been answered just in the
process of you answering other questions
so let's hear their names anyway okay
thanks a lot i'll talk to you later i
gotta go
let's hear their names anyways
yeah rebecca asked a question about well
what why would space suddenly inflate
and what makes it inflate which he would
say check box there yeah yeah but jeff
hunt says um
as a layman i understand the cosmic
microwave background radiation to be the
echo of the radiation from the moment
the universe starts to cool
what is our current understanding of
what existed before the temperature
dropped enough for it to become visible
ah so that's another very astute
question so the cmb or cosmic microwave
background are the oldest photons in the
universe so what we want to do is
explain where did those photons come
from and why did we just get to see them
as they were 380 000 years after the big
bang so those photons are i want to see
them 379 000 years after the big bang
okay wow
come back on the show when you can tell
me that all right yeah you need a time
machine and electric okay telescopes
like this time machines or telescopes or
time machines right so when we look at
the cmb we ask where did those photons
come from and then of course we're going
to ask where did the matter and the
plasma that made those photons which is
what they are originating from where did
that come from where did the thing that
came before where the inflaton come from
i'm sure one of your audience is going
to ask me that right so that's what we
do in science and we may come to a point
where we have to throw up our hands and
say we don't know but we're not ready to
do that yet because in a sense we
haven't reached the limit of what data
can tell us so the answer to the
directly answer the question is those
photons are the leftover heat that come
from the fusion of of hydrogen and its
isotopes into helium lithium
beryllium and the lightest you know five
or six different elements on the
periodic table that occurred in the
first few minutes after the big bang and
then there was really a plasma that the
universe was too hot right after you
nuclearly fuse uh and that's not a word
but you fuse together two protons you
are left over with enormous amounts of
heat that's how the sun produces so much
heat and light well that heat and light
doesn't allow atoms to form so an atom
is a bond binding of a proton and an
electron that makes the hydrogen atom so
the nucleus of hydrogen is proton and
then the electron come together the
universe was simply too hot it was being
zapped by photons anytime a hydrogen
atom deigned to form it would get
immediately zapped apart ionized as we
say and that occurred until the heat
cooled off due to the expansion of the
universe and that took
380 000 years yeah so what did the
universe look like before that it was an
opaque plasma it was essentially two
plasmas a plasma of which is a the
fourth state of matter it's a purely
conductive
medium made up of pure protons or pure
electrons uh charged particles and
charged particles are opaque so a mirror
is actually not a bad representation of
a plasma plasmas reflect all the photons
and they if there's enough plasma in
three dimensions unlike a mirror which
is two dimensional then the plasma will
just keep reflecting the light and it's
kind of like a cloud or a
three-dimensional mirror if you will the
light can't escape and then finally the
day came normally when we think of
opaque we're not thinking of a glowing
object so this is this is a a full
three-dimensional glowing
thing yes that is the universe that you
can't see through much like i guess the
sun you can't see through the sun you
can't see through the sun traps any
light that tries to
any light photons that hit it are just
going to bounce around or just be yeah
yep it'll be a bouncing around so
plasmas are opaque but neutral atoms are
transparent so once hydrogen could form
the universe went from a plasma to
plasmas as i said to a single gas of
hydrogen and that took about 380
thousand years it didn't happen
instantaneously like it's much like a
condensation process you have steam in a
shower if you ever go to a steam shower
you can't see through the steam it looks
like a fog none of us have ever showered
uh yeah so you better give an example
here i'm glad we're not doing this in
person neil i'm glad we're not doing
this in person i've never seen a steam
show of course we've seen what kind of
ques
have you ever been to a turkish bath
that's
we saw
we all have good hygiene i think in my
audience here but go on
so uh you know that if you have a steamy
shower and then you turn on cold water
the water vapor condenses and makes
liquid and then you can see in the
shower so that process the analog of
that process is the formation of
hydrogen then the universe became
transparent and we see those leftover
photons which have their beginning in
the fiery cauldron that produce the
first elements on the periodic table
so i i think it'd be a cool trick if you
could turn the sun
into a transparent ball of gas rather
than the plasma that it is yeah and just
watch that happen and then it would just
basically disappear right and you get to
see what was behind it did you just pour
some cold water in there ah that that's
all you need to just add a little bit of
cold
in the plasma shower
related to this eric varga asks why is
there only one type of wavelength of
light microwaves to see the cosmic
background why do we not have
ultraviolet or gamma or radio cosmic
backgrounds love it that's a great
question go for it so i said that the
cosmic microwave background it is a
relic at a temperature i classified that
by its temperature the bl the universe
and the cosmic microwave background
photons is an example of what's called a
black body radiation source a black body
these were first discovered and their
properties were explained by planck in
1900 and they are reflective of the fact
that any object made of ordinary matter
right don't use the word reflective in
that sentence oh yeah it's a different
word pun intended neil
fun without discretion they were
absorptive
that's right
so they were they are representative of
the fact that you heat up anything
including an iron rod or a ball of
hydrogen and helium like the sun to any
temperature it will emit a broad range
of wavelengths so in fact there were
originally wavelengths of light that
were invisible because they were too
short for the human eye to see they were
ultraviolet they were equivalent to the
energy that's required to zap apart a
hydrogen atom into a proton and an
electron
so that uh that energy level corresponds
to a wavelength of light that was very
small but since the universe has been
expanding all the wavelengths in that
black body which kind of looks like a
bell curve the distribution of energy
versus wavelength the peak today has
been redshifted by 1 000 times the the
value that it had when the hydrogen gas
first condensed 380 000 years after the
big bang not 380 000 years ago 13
billion 800 million years ago and so
since that time the universe has been
expanding by a factor of a thousand and
it went from ultraviolet and if you just
do the math the ultraviolet wavelength
expand it by a thousand times you get
about two millimeter wavelength but
that's just the peak there are uh there
it's like a bell curve there are indeed
photons of shorter wavelength and longer
wavelength in the black body
distribution so why doesn't anyone talk
about them
because they're the the peak is
exponentially decaying on either side so
you have massively easier time detecting
the peak photons um then you do have the
shorter or longer ones but in fact uh
penzies and wilson did detect uh the
short the longer wavelength less
energetic photons uh to uh almost 150
times lower in energy uh than the
photons that we detect today with our
more advanced technology okay cool so we
could in fact have a re a cosmic radio
wave spectrum or a cosmic
uh infrared spectrum but
we don't reference it that way because
that's that's the um
the the emissions in those band passes
is meager that's right and so you're
really labeling it by
you know also when we talk about the sun
the sun peaks in the visible part of the
spectrum but
i think if you add up all the infrared
coming from the sun it's actually we
have more infrared than visible light
yeah i think i did the math on that yeah
that's right and you can detect it with
your hand with your eyes closed you know
yeah i guess so yeah there you go
at least here's
yeah yeah there you go
all right matt give me some more all
right so uh jared sober asks uh sorber
rather says what do we make of the more
recent data that seems to indicate
inflation may not be
as even as we thought uh if so is the
new physics the same physics with
slightly different implications or too
early to tell see i think you answered
the first part of that a bit earlier on
yeah but i like that so let me let me
add a little nuance to that question
brian so um if the inflation is not
symmetric i and i'm not up on that news
story but but
at what point do you say we just need to
tweak the inflation rather than say oh
my gosh we need new physics
so that's one of these many cosmic
controversies as the brits might say uh
that that are there's america jack
okay
don't forget the bronx accent yeah break
out your frogs yeah i'll break down my
long island accent you don't have to
like pretend you're going to be british
no this is american jack you're from new
york city
okay
uh so when we do observe the cosmos the
first thing that you'd want to say is
that the universe is isotropic as i said
before but not perfectly isotropic and
it should be homogeneous which means
that it should be um the same kind of
physical properties everywhere in the
universe but it should also look the
same everywhere you are in the universe
on average okay i can't tell you that
every single star should look identical
to every other single star in every
direction we look of course not but our
theory of inflation predicts that there
should be an expansion of the universe
and only in kind of models that don't
obey perfect cosmological symmetry in
other words what's called the
cosmological principle which is an
extension of what's called the
copernican principle which is basically
i call it the cosmic big brother that
says you're not special you ain't so
great you know it says that the earth is
not the center of the universe somebody
needs therapy
not all big brothers
treated their kid brothers that way just
understand i can only speak for how i
treat my yeah thank you okay uh so when
we uh when when we assume that the
universe is on bulk scales homogeneous
and isotropic that means that if we find
a departure from that we're really
calling into question the the underlying
symmetries that we expect the universe
to to hold to now i should say there are
alternatives to inflation which have
caused even more controversy
that that people believe that inflation
is not only incorrect not only not good
science but there are even those that
say it is bad for society to accept
inflation so this this rose to a head in
19 2017 when a scientific american
article was published by my friend anna
aegis paul steinhardt at princeton the
two of them and uh and avi loeb who's at
harvard and they published an article in
scientific american said the universe
inflation leads to this concept called
the multiverse and the multiverse to
them this is their opinion uh spelled
the end of the scientific method because
in the multiverse it literally means
that i have a podcast called uh called
likely science and that matt has a
podcast called probably impossible and
neil has talked anyway it says that
everything that possibly can happen
according to linday guth and others does
happen in this capacious universe um so
they claim these three authors claim it
was inconsequential inconsistent with
the scientific method then there was a
letter written by 30 nobel prize winners
and and guggenheim fellows and a
responsa to it rick david kaiser and
alan guth and many others geeks right
geek fight it was a fight it was
incredible i couldn't believe it on the
pages of scientific american it's like
the inquisition and they said this is
wrong you're not you're not scientist no
you're not scientist um but just to be
clear that original letter
uh that group were espousing a
completely different model for the
universe
that's right and what is currently here
so so they
it so
they already we already peaked their
whole card right right exactly well
they're going to write a letter what
what do you think's going to be in the
letter or they're going to say everybody
else is wrong and they're right that's
right we're going to take another break
and when when we come back
let's try to like do maybe a lightning
round yeah all right matt do you think
brian has that in him
i think he does we've got we this is i i
think even still we're not going to get
through all of them because this was one
of the most popular one of the most
popular yeah you know i don't think
brian has it in him he's got a
mixed explainer there
we'll see how he does on a sound bite
mode all right when star talk continues
uh we're back star talk cosmic queries
cosmology
early universe edition
with brian keating and brian you you do
a lot of stuff for the public i was very
impressed to see
you visit high schools you've written
books uh you're so you're a man about
town bringing your your expertise to all
those who will listen and you do it well
enough so that that's a growing supply
of people because you could you could
bring it to all we'll listen today
that could get halved every day if you
really suck at it so
very good to see that this is a growing
yeah i i'm a little controversial
because i i say i believe that
scientists such as myself uh have a
moral obligation to give an explanation
to the public i i don't think that's
controversial so
well i mean my colleagues think it is i
mean they say well why are you wasting
your time on the youtube channel yeah
of course they're gonna say that of
course they're going to say that right
okay we are not among those who feel
that way about you exactly because
youtube channel is doing better than
theirs no that's exactly i would kill
for them to i would give them my
following
they don't even have a youtube channel
that's like the problem that's the
problem uh so so matt
we're going to test brian here to see if
he has sound bites in him all right see
how many questions we can get through
all right so tightening my lightning
mode let's do this here we go don lane
asks how much will the expanding nature
of the universe figure into interstellar
navigation computations
uh absolutely negligible the universe is
expanding less than about one second uh
per century on the appropriate scales it
will not be observable in your lifetime
let alone in the navigational you know
kind of trajectory so you know keep so
any place you want to go to before you
die is way less than any time of
significance with regard to the
expanding universe exactly all right
good there it is nice one all right
chris hampton asks could our universe be
expanding because it is filling with
space-time fluid and could the reason it
keeps accelerating be because there are
more quote faucets opening up okay so
brian who who left the spigot on
the universe according to my wife it's
always me neil
always me uh
um yeah uh actually the answer is very
uh the question's very perceptive
because essentially the notion of of the
uh dark energy which is the responsible
party for the accelerating universe not
only is the universe getting bigger
every day the rate at which it's getting
bigger is getting bigger every day
therefore we have a time derivative of a
velocity that's called cosmic
acceleration so we equate right it's
called just acceleration and this as
applied to the universe cosmic
acceleration yes exactly right so um so
indeed this substance has what's called
an equation of state and that equation
of state is a relationship between a
substances pressure when you try to
compress it and versus its uh versus its
density how how many uh uh ergs per
cubic centimeter how much energy there
is per cubic centimeter so actually the
the flubber-like material it's not a
fluid the dark energy we don't know
exactly what it is but we know what it
is not it's not a fluid like water water
has very different pressure density
relationships but it has a strange
relationship which when you try to
compress it it says oh okay great
instead of resisting it like water would
it says i love this let me suck you in
and it's kind of like an
anti-gravitational force
so it's not fluid like water but it is
filled with an equation of state and if
you say it like that you sound more
erudite and you'd be correct and the
answer is yes to this question
and it is a space-time fluid not a
traditional fluid that we might
otherwise think of exactly okay there
you go keep it coming man okay alejandro
reynoso says hola from monterrey mexico
and what new discoveries do you think we
can get from the bicep project project
ah so the bicep project is a project i
started way back in 2001 we built a
polarimeter which is a telescope first
why what bicep what what is it what so
bicep is a corny name that i came up
with it stands for background imager of
cosmic extragalactic polarization so i
said that inflation is not proven but
there is one signal which we would hope
to detect and it's called gravitational
radiation or waves of gravity produced
by the violent shaking and shuddering of
space-time
einstein predicts that will cause waves
of gravity to percolate throughout the
cosmos have we found it with ligo are
they looking for you no ligo cannot see
this it's way too weak because the
universe has expanded by a factor of
trillions and trillions of times since
the inflationary epoch we can only see
it with a with a microwave telescope to
look at the imprints of these waves on
the cmb we're using the cmb nail as the
detector that's so phenomenal
so okay so you can't you can't you can't
measure a but you can measure a's effect
on b because you can measure b yeah
we're putting our numbers
right at the source so in 2001 i came up
with an experiment with colleagues at
caltech which we call bicep like i said
it's the subject of this book losing the
nobel prize and that's it right there if
you're watching on the uh on screen
otherwise i'm showing a picture of our
telescope at the south pole antarctica
where i've been twice we put a telescope
there and we've upgraded it ever since
in 2014. just to be clear the address of
the south pole is south pole comma
antarctica
or you can send it to negative 90
degrees negative 90 degrees
it actually has a post office and you
actually have a gift shop there negative
90 degrees and any longitude will do
right because they all converge
every direction leads north exactly to
the south pole okay so so was it
successful we're still in soundbite mode
here so that was 01 that's 20 years ago
so yeah so bicep made an announcement
2014 we detected inflation we detected
these waves of gravity uh turned out we
detected cosmic dust particles of dust
in our galaxy not the impermanent of
inflation oh my god stuff sitting on our
nose in our own galaxy
bicep is still flexing away and so is
it's it's uh it's other um the project i
lead now with my colleagues called the
simon's observatory which is uh going to
be the most advanced cosmic microwave
background experiment ever named after
jim simons right the wealthy investors
in maryland that's right who's very very
into science and math that's a good
thing
all right matt let's keep going all
right rouhan uh perrier cherry asks uh
from the bay area says is it possible
that a new universe is born every time
another universe dies say via big rip or
bounce we say multiverse like there are
multiple universes existing parallel to
us in some higher dimension but what if
that higher dimension is actually time
itself
very good yeah so in fact there are
multiple versions of the multiverse as
kind of this question is hinting at
there's a quantum mechanical multiverse
there's a many worlds multiverse there's
cosmological but also there is an
alternative to inflation which avoids
the multiverse problem and that's called
a cyclic or bouncing cosmological model
which does feature a universe collapsing
if you will to create our universe that
we see and there's no reason that
couldn't happen multiple times in
multiple places um throughout the
universe so exactly correct
all right all right are you getting
better there brian with you with your
sound bites okay i'm going to combine
these two questions because these are
two things that i struggle with
conceptually so but again i want to know
who i want to know who asked them too oh
i will do absolutely so daniel uh
kowalski uh sorry kalikowski rather uh
says
if the cosmic microwave uh background is
radiation expanding outward from the big
bang how we how are we able to see the
light here on earth wouldn't the
radiation be traveling towards the edges
of the universe and that's not visible
to us thanks for helping me understand
this and then okay so rob robert weaver
from michigan says i understand it's not
possible to see beyond our cosmic
horizon as light has had not enough time
to travel to us if that is true in space
and high and space is expanding faster
than light are we forever landlocked in
regards to the observable universe no
matter how fast we go the edge is
traveling faster away from us so we
never see more than we do now but
actually less as time goes on i like the
landlocked concept there i don't know
whether those two are connected or not
but they felt conceptually connected so
i checked
yeah brian what can you do for us here
all right so imagine two observers
albert and his evil twin
and they separate faster than the speed
of light as long as they started out
closer in distance that such that their
light could have when this light was
launched from one of the two observers
it could have maintained its velocity
and trajectory towards the other
observer it doesn't matter how far away
that thing is now we look at when it was
emitted when it was detected and it
doesn't matter where that galaxy is now
so it is true there is a whole branch of
objects in the universe in fact i did a
calculation for my cosmology class which
i'm going to teach in a few minutes and
that showed that 97 of the universe by
volume is causally disconnected can
never communicate landlocked in the
words of your poetic i love different i
love that reference yeah yeah so so that
means that yeah we can't see those
objects doesn't mean we couldn't see
them in the beginning because in the
beginning they were not expanding they
weren't at redshift greater than one as
cosmologists call it so indeed they we
can still see them but we can never
access them and there's a difference
between being able to see their original
emission and being able to contact them
now so exactly correct they are isolated
from us by cosmological
event horizon brian you're doing good
here and then and then the second part
of how can we see uh the cosmic
background radiation if the universe is
expanding away from us yeah let me let
me reword that as i think i understand
it if the if the if 380 000 years ago
all these photons were set free
well they should be
in some way beyond us today
uh on route to exit the universe or
whatever why are they still headed
towards us
well so they're the photons are
traveling towards us and at the time of
their emission we work physically closer
to them and since that time of emission
the time at which the cmb was formed the
universe expanded by a factor of a
thousand times so a photon would have
had been within our cosmic horizon it
would have been access able to access us
just like any object that's at a
redshift greater than one you could ask
that question of any object the cmb is
at a red shift of eleven hundred so uh
so the answer is similar to the answer i
just gave it launch the photons such
that they will reach us with the exact
trajectory just reaching us now and the
the process of this formation of the cmb
was not instantaneous and we will see
continue to see those photons but caveat
that we won't see them with the
wavelength that they were originally
emitted as we described earlier in the
show so what you're saying is it was on
route to us today from the beginning is
what you're saying we were in it's
future light cone exactly nice nice so
it moved not only through space but
through time
as of course these things go all right
matt keep it going we're blowing through
these
all right megan munoz says is it
possible
that space is created in a black hole i
have this weird theory that the matter
that goes into a black hole may be torn
apart so much that it literally turns to
space and i mean not only does the
object disintegrate but in the process
more space is created than was
originally taken up by the mass maybe
that's why space expands that is the new
space could make that is if the new
space could make it outside of the black
hole can i have a scholarship has megan
done enough to re to get a professorship
from one of you guys so so brian if he
has any answer other than i don't know
let's ask him when was the last time he
visited the inside of a black hole okay
go shower exactly
so right so i get about uh 10 letters a
week saying you know einstein was wrong
i can prove it but i'm not good at math
so can you share the nobel prize with me
the answer you do the math and you
figure it out and that's right i'll keep
the nobel prize thank you um so no we we
have no evidence for that it doesn't
mean it's not possible there are people
that do predict that time is created
when black holes uh at the uh beyond
inside the event horizon singularity but
we have no way to access it it is behind
the event horizon so even if it did get
produced like hawking radiation we've
heard about hawking radiation
undoubtedly that radiation exists but
it's it's it's so impossible even in in
practice to envision detecting it it's
all but irrelevant as is unfortunately
your new theory sorry scholarship
damn
that was a smackdown if i ever heard one
at least take me out for a drink before
you asked me for a scholarship oh man
man matt i don't know i don't think we
have any time for any more matt do we
leave a lot on the cutting room floor oh
there there are so many good questions
yeah you could do a whole second maybe
even three episodes of of cosmic queries
we will totally have to do another
episode on this well uh brian it's been
great having you on i think i think your
first time on star talk and it is my
first time let's make sure it's not the
last
so matt you're you're a comedian so uh
is that what you do at nights
after sunset
yeah that's the after dark job so yeah i
i i post what shows i'm doing on on
twitter uh at mackerson and then uh
probably science is the podcast and i
mentioned my show's on there as well so
and you do stand up so if you want to
find you find out what city you're in
we'll we can find you
on your website and and brian uh how can
we find you in the social media pantheon
i'm at dr brian keating uh twitter
instagram and uh my website uh
briankeating.com
if you join my mailing list i will send
you all a piece of space dust a
meteorite from the origin of time and
space itself briankeating.com is the way
to find me that's that's a little
suspicious there but okay i'll let you
have that
let's see how big the space dust is
isn't all matter in some level space
dust that's true as carl sagan said we
are a rock a mode of dust floating on a
sunbeam yeah yeah there you go
well the earth was on some beam yeah all
right guys this has been star talk
cosmic queries
the cosmology edition clearly we're
gonna have to do some more of these
brian good to have you matt always good
to see you
thanks my friends neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
[Music]
you